I know you've written quite a bit about
Egypt and how you feel about the
conflicts throughout these last few
years some people say look is this what
we saw two years ago all over again and
you say not really yeah this is not the
start of the revolution this is a
continuation of the revolution and what
you see is that the majority of Egyptian
are trying to press the reset button on
the revolution because they know that
that's critical to the national
reconciliation that's needed to go
forward so what do you think needs to
happen because the president is facing
this deadline from the military how
serious do you think the military is
about intervening what do you think
could happen how can this end this is a
very serious situation because Egypt
lacks strong institutions lacks a leader
like Nelson Mandela that can focus the
country forward and therefore the people
are trying to reclaim the revolution so
this is a critical moment the Army is
the strongest among a weak set of
institutions so that's why people are
looking to the Army and the Army is in a
difficult situation so this is very
unpredictable there's no playbook for
this beti at all and the next few hours
and days are going to be absolutely
critical has mercy been given a chance I
mean you know it's hard enough to try to
take a company out of chaos but it are a
company a country out of chaos but it's
even harder as we saw what happened two
years ago for him to come up with the
support of the Muslim Brotherhood but to
come up in a country that has been has
been essentially in turmoil over the
last several decades so the two
complaints against him one is that he
hasn't done enough to bolster the
economy and meet social needs and he
inherited a very difficult situation the
second one is one of overreach that he
took his mandate a deal at the ballot
box
and rather than earn it every day he
assumed that he could do things that was
beyond what society would accept and
then it's the second one that said the
source of a lot of what you see in the
street today
Mohamed what's the chance that this is
going to spill over into further unrest
only in that region but around the world
you know it's a very tricky question
because if you look at traditional
measures of contagion trade links
financial links global demand and supply
influences they're low but Egypt has a
special role in the region is it the
biggest most influential country and it
has lots of demonstration effects so
it's very difficult to measure the
contagion effects to any of the
traditional indicators and that's why
the market has woken up late to this
issue and is very nervous including also
by the way what's happening in Europe
Europe is another issue is making
nervous in markets quite nervous
mohammad as i mentioned i mean you you
know you partly grew up in egypt and and
you're you know you're looking at this
from the outside but you're also very
much a part of the fabric there what
side are you want what do you what do
you personally hope to see so i
personally hope to see that critical
pivot in any revolution from this
mounting repressive past which each of
did in 18 days to building a more
promising future which is really hard i
would love to see that pivot happened
because if that divot happens this is a
country that can achieve what but you
want Morsi to stay or go yeah I think at
this stage the country has to move on I
think at this stage what I would
recommend to President Morsi is look
step down
you cannot govern if you don't have the
majority of people on your side and work
within a context and orderly context for
a transition that's what I would
recommend but it's very hard for people
to do that